we're getting this from countered
terrorism policing Southeast you've been
working with Kent Police on the incident
that took place and Dover Immigration
Center a man throwing fire bombs at the
center in that vehicle you can see there
in that picture he was then found dead
by police
um this information coming to us an
update from Kent Police that said that
the suspect has now been identified as
Andrew leak aged 66 from High Wickham a
search one was carried out at a property
in the High Wycombe area in
buckinghamshire on Monday and there is
currently nothing to suggest that the
man involved was working alongside
anyone else and there's not believed to
be any wider threat to the community in
the High Wycombe area or Dover just
another interesting line from this
statement it says what appears clear is
that this despicable offense was
targeted and likely to be driven by some
form of hate-filled grievance though
this may not necessarily meet the
threshold of terrorism at this point the
incident itself has not been declared a
terrorist incident